merci pierre rancourt et l'applaudir le
premier intervenant l'excellente député
du doubs genevard qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur ces questions
d'aménagement du territoire elle a animé
une table ronde lors des dernières
journées parlementaires des républicains
ares et annie va nous parler d'une
notion qui est un petit peu nouvelle
c'est de travailler sur l'échelle des
bassins de vie pour résoudre les
problèmes de nos populations rurales à
l'échelle d'un bassin de vie voilà
aniche cède la parole de suite merci
jean louis bonjour à tous
alors tout d'abord 77% des bassins de
vie sont des bassins de vie ruraux donc
ça pose déjà le cadre général de notre
réflexion et appréhender le territoire
sous l'angle des bassins de vie ça revêt
donc un sens particulier dans la
ruralité
ce sont des territoires qui ne sont pas
dictées par des concours des contours
administratifs et ce d'autant que ses
contours administratifs ont beaucoup
évolué et que la loi notre les cantons
se sont élargies les régions également
les communautés de communes aussi et
revenir finalement au bon sens qui
consiste à dire ma bassin de vie c'est
tout simplement le pasa fonctionnel
c'est le bassin le territoire sur lequel
les gens les gens vivent et bien ça
permet de développer des politiques qui
sont qui sont ajustés
alors quand on parle de bassin de vie ça
qu'on roule ça concerne tout de même 21
millions de personnes c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait importante
alors ces 21 millions de personnes
qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent les attendent
à un territoire un territoire
fonctionnel sur lequel on va trouver des
services marchands public également des
emplois des équipements et de ce point
de vue
je voudrais attirer l'attention de
l'auditoire sur ce qu'on appelle les
bourgs centres dans la ruralité il y a
des petites villes qui vont structurer
la ruralité et leur rôle est tout à fait
capital c'est pour ça que on appelle on
les appelle déboursant parce que il les
exerce sur le territoire qui les
entourent une fonction de centralité
alors il ya un phénomène nouveau qui
s'est développé ces dernières années
c'est la fragilisation des bourgs
centres
on a vu disparaître de nos villages un
certain nombre de services un certain
nombre de commerces
je ne reviendrai pas dessus chacun le
sait parce qu'on a tous une expérience
de la ruralité soit parce qu'on n'y a de
la famille soit parce que on y passe des
vacances et puis parce que ce sont les
racines de chacun on a vu disparaître au
fur et à mesure les cafés les écoles les
bureaux de poste dans les villages mais
il ya un phénomène nouveau c'est que
cette fragilisation des a gagné
progressivement les bourgs centres et
aujourd'hui dans ces petits pôles
urbains qui structure la ruralité et
bien on voit des commerces qui se vide
on voit des services qui disparaissent
et évidemment cela fragilise beaucoup le
rôle de centralité et ça inquiète la
population et on y reviendra dans le
dans cette table ronde
il ya un service en particulier qui est
en train de quitter les bourses entre et
c'est une source d'inquiétude
énorme pour la population la première
source d'inquiétude
dans toutes les enquêtes que l'on fait
on voit que ce qui préoccupe les gens
qui habitent en ruralité c'est pas la
fermeture de l'école parce que l'école
on sait qu'elle va se reconstituer avec
dans le village d'à côté ça n'est pas le
bureau de poste parce qu'avec la
dématérialisation des échanges
la poste aujourd'hui c'est important
mais c'est moins vital que ce n'était
autrefois ce sont les services de la
santé parce que la santé évidemment ça
touche chacun d'entre nous alors lorsque
le médecin de village est parti il est
allé dans la ville d'à côté mais lorsque
dans la ville d'à côté le médecin a 120
ans retraité qu'il n'est pas remplacé
évidemment c'est un sujet d'inquiétude
majeur
alors cette fragile
isation déboursant cet affaiblissement
de leurs fonctions centralité les
socialistes l'ont bien compris ils ont
identifié le phénomène ils ont identifié
le phénomène et ils ont dit que c'était
très grave
jusque là on est d'accord c'est dans les
réponses apportées dans les réponses
apportées on voit là quelque chose qui
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur des
enjeux puisque madame pinel a lancé une
expérimentation sur 50 bourses entre
lorsqu'il y a plus de 1200 bassin de vie
ruraux et c'est là évidemment que il
faut nous inscrire en faux et puis faire
des contre-propositions parce que la
présence de boer animé et dynamique est
un gage de qualité de vie de cohésion
sociale et territoriale et de
développement économique local
alors je terminerai mon propos en vous
livrant une petite anecdote personnelle
lorsque j'étais conseillère régionale en
franche comté avant que la bourgogne se
joignent à nous le président de la
région de franche comté était raymond
fournier l'ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale qui était un homme
vraiment très politique assez durs et un
jour moi je suis une élue rural jeu
l'interpellait sur la ruralité et il me
dit ah mais vous vous à droite la
ruralité et votre fond de commerce
électoral
et cette phrase m'est resté parce qu'au
fond elle dit tout le préjugé qu'il y a
chez nos adversaires politiques à
l'égard de la rue réalité non non la
ruralité n'est pas un fonds de commerce
électoral
elle est une partie essentielle du
territoire national elle concerne une
proportion considérable des français et
en plus la ruralité c'est se rappeler à
nous elle a été négligée trop longtemps
elle sait se rappeler à nous par ces
agriculteurs lors des consultations
électorales
et puis aussi parce que nous ne devons
pas avoir un point de vue trop
misérabiliste sur la ruralité c'est
aussi un territoire d'innovation
c'est aussi un territoire de réussie
et c'est bien cela qu'il faut encourager
c'est la raison pour laquelle tu l'a
rappelé jean louis
on a fait de la ruralité le sujet de nos
journées parlementaires
et c'est parce que nous avons choisi aux
républicains d'y consacrer toute une
convention je vous remercie